hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Riga Fida grand
prix 2019 it's Alexandria versus Nikita
way to go Val are we have requested this
game as it really is very nice so two of
the classical games have been run and
now we enter the rapid games so without
further ado let's check out the nice
photo that we have of this matchup there
you have it a Grisha can left
Viterbo on the right now if not looking
at the board maybe maybe you know not
wanting an Akita to see you know through
his preparation and the cube of you know
deep in thought preparing to well play
the game so let's check it out
we have Knight to f3 the ready is on the
board we have Knight to f6 sorry about
that
we have c4 e6 Knight to c3 and now a b5
I just challenging the center we have d4
so going into the the Queens gambit
declined with Knight B to d7 and now
bush of the f4 by Griff shock we have D
captures on c4 now comes a e3 preparing
to recapture on c4 and now Knight the
d-pad d5 is the most mostly played move
here but with Knight the b6 by virtue of
seemingly defending the c4 pawn but not
really
Grisha just grabs it and gives up the
bishop pair quite early but it is the
line that the line goes this way we have
Knight captures and now Quintus a quick
way for check will pick up the knight c6
blocking Czech Queen captures on c4 and
now Knight to d5 offering more trades so
Grisha
of course not interested in giving up
the bishop the Darkspore brush up to g3
and now Queen to b6 going after the beat
upon initial defense at queen te - it's
okay to Castle I mean it's the pawn
isn't poisoned but white will get a game
if he sacrifices the pawn
then his kismat - Lina tried it in 2018
once and well the game ended in a draw
but it was a very nice game however okay
Grisha goes Queen back to e - defending
the b2 pawn and now Bishop to b4 now
challenging the night here as well it
spins so now the video is preparing to
capture it good issue castles here since
the black king is still in the center
you don't mind giving up a pawn for
something
and now if you capture with the bishop
it's not all that great if you capture
with the bishop captures and captures
comes with an attack on the queen but
queen d3 attack is the night and after
95 e for now you can't go Knight c7
since rook F b1 attacks the Queen and
the Queen really should keep an eye on
the night since the bishop is attacking
c7 so you're probably gonna go east 7
but now white will prevent you from
castling Bishop to b6 now I can't castle
as your knight is under attack and if
Queen d8 just go into a three black
still will not be able to castle we're
gonna have to play f6 Castle
artificially and well ruin your your
pawn structure
so here the Vic you go goes the Knight
captures pawn captures Bishop captures
attacks the rook and rook a b1 just we
have an attack on the Queen Queen back
to d8 and now rook the b3 a very nice
rook lift with the idea that after these
two pieces move away from the
third-ranked and the point is pushed to
e4 you will be able to transfer the rook
over to the Kings side to use it you
know for attacks
bushra back to a5 and now efore and here
well it is okay the castle first we tuba
wants the will gain some control of the
e5 square you don't wanna allow ninety
five and also he's offering a trade of
bishops so here if you trade bishops and
you try something like nice to e5 yes
now the rook can come over to the to the
King side to start an attack but it's
okay the castle because now rook to h3
yes you are threatening Queen to h5 but
black can defend just f6 you attack the
knight and after Queen to h5 threatening
to capture here you will play g5 and now
the Queen from c7 guards h7 that's the
point
and now the knight has to go back and
the game continues
but after Bishop to c7 Grisham's not
interested in trading bishops with
Bishop to h4 attacking the Queen and now
Queen to d7 just getting the Queen out
of way and preparing the castle we have
looked a d1 here and now what do you
play here well this is a kind of the
point of the game because this is one of
the one of the positions where it's not
only okay to play a six it's actually
the best move here you have to prevent
95 and f6 is the only way to do it
and
though you're not really preventing a
five white will play nice to e5 because
he wants to open up the D file but now
you can just move the Queen Queen e7 and
after Queen to h5 check you can play g6
because Knight captures and g6 doesn't
work here I are gonna just play Queen to
f7 and white loses a piece here so here
after g6 you will have to play Queen to
h6 but now Queen to f8 kicks the Queen
back so it's not a problem you've
prevented the whites attack and after
the Queen moves you will then you know
be able to consolidate but the V to go
here played castles and to now it simply
doesn't work so I would ask you to pause
the video here and try to find the best
move for white but as I already told you
that f6 is the best move in that
position very shook played Knight to e5
here and it's really hard to pinpoint
why this is just winning for white but
it is it's really just a beautiful move
because if you capture the knight Bishop
captures pawn captures then you've
opened up well an attack towards the
Queen and after the Queen moves it
doesn't matter if the Queen moves the EI
tort or hurt
c7 the attack continues in the same
fashion for example after Queen to e8
you will get a rook to d8 is possible
and the white does get an advantage but
black will just grab material for the
Queen the best a continuation for white
is Bishop to f6 and now just everything
wins for white there's no way to defend
here if you capture the bishop then just
Queen to g4 check King moves and now
Queen to h4 with the threat of Queen
captures on f6 followed by rock to g3
mate and after a black defense Queen e7
now you go rook to h3 and there's no
defense against rook captures on h7 so
this is one of the possibilities on the
other hand after Bishop to f6 if you
don't capture it you can play g6 maybe
you want to play something like that
then you get a really beautiful Queen to
h5 and now either white will play Queen
h6 fall back when g7 mate or black will
capture and then its mate in one
rug g3 because the bishop covers the
dark squares and other than that if you
don't capture or even play g6 if you try
something completely different I mean
there's really no good
to play here whatever you play let's
ambush a b7 the the attack that just
happens by itself is just when G for you
attack threaten checkmate and after g6
will get the same idea just queen h5 and
now it's either again mate with Queen
Queen h6 fall back when g7 or captures
and mate in one
so after Knight to e5 v cubed decides
okay we're not touching this Knight
let's just move the Queen he played the
Queen to d8 but now again does Queen e8
really change all that much
no Grisha just continues to Bishop to f6
and now if you trade the Bishop captures
pawn captures we already get at the same
position that we've just analyzed so
we're not even gonna consider capturing
what do you play here
Bishop to d8 be Cuba wants to trade the
bishops but now again feel free to pause
the video and try to continue this
attack for white there is only one good
attacking idea here and I'm sure you all
know where this is going
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
attacker and for those of you who just
won't enjoy Bishop captures on g7 and
now if you don't capture then you're
just lost
I mean Ruby e3 is coming you can even
grab rook and be out material so
obviously the only the only answer is to
capture the bishop which is what an
Akita played with King captures on g7
here look the g3 check and now you only
have two viable options the problem is
King to f6 is a forced mate
and it's a very nice force mate Queen f3
check King the e7 now Queen to a3 check
the night covers d7 so you have to go
back King to f6 and not Knight to d7
check making room for a 5 well the Queen
covers the e7 square black has the
capture doesn't really matter which what
Bishop captures now comes a 5 and now
these squares are not available for you
you have to go down the board King f5
and Queen to f3 is checkmate
so after rook to g3 check we took of
decided to go King the h8 but now we
should just play it Queen to h5 and it
was in this position that nikita v-cube
of resigned the game and since the two
classic games were drawn a Greek one
both the game would white and black in
the rapid so he knocked out Nikita B to
go from the Auriga feed a Grand Prix
very very exciting game the the game
were
a good issue had the black pieces was
also very nice but this is just
demolishing so here you don't really
have a good reply to rock h3 and queen
to h7 mate if you try rook g8 - maybe
block it off it doesn't really work
because now Knight captures on f7 you
cannot move the King you have to give up
the Queen and now it's all over and if
you don't move the rook you could try
something like Queen e7 to push f5 sorry
f5 to guard eh 7 point but after loop to
h3 and well f5 you get this very nice
check very nice family fork here and
there you have it
sorry my colouring is off today no no no
capturing is possible here because the
point is pinned you have to move King g8
now comes captures with check and now as
well mate in one
so after Queen to h5 which you have
resigned and a very nice victory for
Alexander Greece you look very happy
you've requested this game as I might
not have seen it there are a lot of
games as there are a lot of players
since it's only the beginning of the
Grand Prix and as there are so many well
things that happened before the
quarterfinals I will just put a link to
it in the description below so you can
check out all the games that have
finished and how they finished and only
after the quarterfinals we will be
showing the standings sure that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank mikaël Cabral Frank combs
and Michael I machine ski for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos your
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully what's more
interesting content and don't forget
even though everyone says it's never ok
to play f6 this is one such example
where it's not only ok to play f6 it is
the best move so always check it maybe
f6 just works in your position thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day